dear chiara dear ladies dear friends
thank you very much for your invitation
to this impressive
gathering all of you who are connected
today
have an amazing story to tell a story of
hard work
and of success some of you were the
first women
in your family to get a degree
others were the first women ceo in your
company
or the first woman president in your
country
none of you were naturally expected in
your roles
you all had to fight to get there you
had to defy conventions
traditions and you had to overcome
obstacles of all kinds
and a lot of you had to fight and work
harder
than your male colleagues we all know
this simply should not be the case
we all want to start and advance on the
level playing field
and it makes me feel bad that we even
have to say that
in 2020.
the pandemic has made some of these
obstacles and
unbalances more visible women have a
much higher risk to lose their job
because of the crisis
it's twice as high compared to men
because many women have more precarious
jobs
but in some cases it's because they have
to take care of their children full time
hardly anyone looks in the direction of
the fathers
the united nations warned that i quote
the pandemic
could set back women's rights by decades
end of quote but there is
nothing inevitable in this
this crisis is once again also an
opportunity
to rethink old patterns and to rethink
behaviors
and let us use these times of disruption
to push for more
positive change all across our economies
i'm thankful that this women's forum has
been pushing exactly
for that you're bringing at the table
thinkers and doers from across the world
we have to grasp this opportunity to
make change
happen by design
so let us create a more sustainable and
livable world
and let us self-confidently point out
the important role that women play on
this path
not because women are better than men
per se
but they are different and their views
matter simply because we can achieve
more sustainable solutions for this
world
if men and women work together on the
same level
as you probably know the european union
developed a
750 billion euro recovery plan
called next generation eu we don't
just want to repair our economy
but we want to prepare it for the future
we want a green recovery
more than one third of our investment
will finance our
european green deal objectives
big resources will go into flagship
projects
such as hydrogen valleys
or a renovation way for our buildings
or the installation of one million
charging points for electric cars
so europe will raise its climate
ambition
because it's vital for our planet
and it's good for our economy
we also want a digital recovery
and we will invest 20 percent of next
generation eu
in this we want to bring high-speed
connectivity to every corner of the
european union
during this crisis we have learned how
important this is
businesses of all size can benefit from
investments in artificial intelligence
and then european data economy for
example
so europe wants to shape the digital
transformation
but most importantly
true recovery has to be inclusive
and this will only happen if women enjoy
the very same opportunities as men
and this is why we will put a special
focus
on digital skills every man and every
woman should be equally fit
to contribute to the economy of the
future
the european union will for instance
invest in programs that will encourage
more girls and women towards stem
education most green and digital jobs
are stem jobs good news is
that in europe by now 41
of scientists and engineers are women
but when you look closer at workers in
high-tech
manufacturing four out of five
are men so still a very long way to go
in raising my daughters i have always
told them
there is no such thing as
jobs for men and jobs for women
some of europe's best scientists and
engineers are women
the italian team that recently
discovered water on mars
is led by a woman elena pettinelli
or this year's nobel prize in chemistry
went to emmanuel chachapunte for her
groundbreaking research on genome
the stem key initiative which you have
launched
is great our recovery plan will invest
in the next
generation of european women in stem
so if not no then when
this also means that women and men
in the jobs market should enjoy the very
same rights and opportunities
and this does not always have to be done
with a rebuking finger
sometimes even clever incentives are
enough
let me tell you a story when i was
family minister in my home country
germany
i introduced incentives for fathers
to take at least two months of parental
leave
after the birth of a child today
more than a third of german fathers take
time with their baby at home and they
love it and it gives the mother the
opportunity to resume her career
and it paves the way for an equal
partnership
with reconciliation of work and family
for both
parents
in the last five years only nine more eu
countries have
either created or extended paternity
leave
the latest to do so was france just two
weeks
a few weeks ago this is the way
maternity and paternity
should never be perceived as being
alternative
to having a career and we can change
culture and customs in
all our societies with the right laws
and yes
with right role models as you are
this kind of change can take time
when i was elected president of the
european commission i
promised that my commission would be the
first
gender balanced one in our history
we asked every european country to
present a man
and a woman as candidates for each post
i tell you it was not easy
but today as the first female president
of the european commission
i lead a team that is gender balanced
so everything can change with a bit of
perseverance
and there is something i have learned in
20 years of politics
leadership is very often about
finding the silver lining in every cloud
yes today the world is in the middle of
a storm
but with the right steer we can design a
fair recovery for all
and a more inclusive world you can count
on me
as i know i can count on you it is a
time for
change let's make it happen together
thank you